zucchi musicanti e guerra 69 kg lasciate
per fare tutto per farne fretta tele
vellutante se siete single vele in
filanti ovunque lo vuole provare signora
muammar romantica fesserie male ti
insegno qua dietro è il paradiso
dell'ortaggio michele banca valle po
davanti cosa cambia con quello normale
in assoluto più bello colorato va di
moda e poi enrico di ossidanti è che
affidano le ossa e solo 9 euro signora
centa ma la qualità si paga e cenova qua
davanti alla bancarella con un euro si
prende tutto il bancone anche pesticidi
queste mele signor sono di una dolcezza
allucinante poi liguria faccio mica
pagare no cara sai come di cucini questi
i fatti che gli iscritti nel boot in
forno a 200 tante cariche un portale
tale quadro la mediana la morte loro non
sono maturi signor ma sta scherzando
guardi che glielo il signor ed ai
pomodori in rosso non va più di moda di
rilascio sa quanto a 6 ore 20 è
carissima eco tech craxi grazie alla
prossima forse aiuti e mi mancano 20
centesimi ma scusa eh vuoi fare la furba
quell'amara